Marshall come out and play
hey y'all Atlanta let's go Nick Cannon
and Eminem are feuding and things are
getting messy which is why we are
breaking down everything you need to
know about what's been going on
let's start with the most recent this
all started last week when Eminem
reignited a feud with both Nick and
Nick's ex Mariah Carey on his new song
with Fat Joe and dr. Dre called Lord
above but that other dudes with them got
him neutered trying to tell him this
chicks a nut job or he got his jewels
Clint I let it too far did you Nick yeah
he literally named drops fast forward to
this week Nick responds with his own
diss track called the invitation where
he brings Eminem's daughter into the mix
called camp somebody get Haley and that
other kid you raised in that ain't even
yo baby the page I heard you so forgot a
video you [ __ ] paid them off delay
them off now who really not then the
tweets started with Eminem first
responding to the claims Nick made about
his sexuality quote you mad bro stop
lying on my I never even had a chauffeur
you bougie mm also demanded Nick
apologized to him quote I demand an
apology
Nicholas you've made my gardener so
jealous
that's when Nick invited Eminem to
settle things a hun wild and out Marco
come out and play
celebs like 50-cent have taken sides
he's obviously team Eminem he's our guy
one of my best friends and I think we
know Mariah is team Nick it's pretty
simple they'll always be unconditional
love and a great relationship one of my
best friends in life so like it's it's
always gonna be that fans think Eminem
is the winner of this fight though with
a hashtag r.i.p
Nick Cannon was trending on Twitter
sometimes the public opinion might want
to paint you a certain way but at the
end of the day that's not what it's
about of course Nick and Eminem's
history goes way back in 2009
Eminem called out the couple in his song
bagpipes from Baghdad that song left
people wondering if Eminem and Raya
teated she claims they did not in that
same year she released obsessed a song
that was seemingly a response to
Eminem's infatuation with her
[Music]
I should also mention Nick's new song
seemingly references that baby mama cue
off a decade ago he's still crying about
no really dope well that was exhausting
hopefully you're all caught up though on
all things Nick vs Eminem here's to
seeing what happens next for all the
latest in this saga stick with all
things he T until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and bye for now
[Music]